here are a few stories that we think you
will be talking about today Russia's
most prominent opposition activist was
released from a hospital this morning
and taken back to jail
after reportedly suffering an acute
allergic reaction while he was in
custody Alexei Navalny was rushed to a
Moscow medical facility yesterday a
spokesperson for the vocal Putin critic
says he had severe facial swelling and
redness a doctor who has previously
treated him says his symptoms are
consistent with chemical poisoning
navami was jailed last week after
calling for pro-democracy protests
thousands of people took part in those
demonstrations Saturday and security
forces detained about 1,400 people it's
amazing 114 hundred and what kicked this
off is 30 local races where people
wanted to run and were barred from
running that's right yeah well we'll ten
hundred people detained novotny's doctor
says she cannot get to him also some
journalists who waited outside of his
hospital were arrested as well yeah
tough going on there in Russia we'll
keep an eye on that